so one of the greatest uses of liquid is
for quantum error correction most of
quantum error correction involves the
simulation of Clifford operations and
liquid contains a simulator optimized
just for this purpose the simulator is
based on Aronson and Goddess man's
original CHP proposal from the early
2000s it takes advantage of the fact
that Clifford gates can be simulated
efficiently and most of quantum error
correction actually just consists of
Clifford operations in addition you can
simulate depolarizing noise efficiently
so you can use liquid to actually study
an error correction protocol under
depolarizing noise and then you can
perform numerics say simulations of the
pseudo thresholds for a huge range of
code distances this can give a really
good idea of the performance of the code
for various distances of the code in
addition you can study more realistic
noise models in liquid using the full
Universal simulator so say you want to
study amplitude damping and dephasing
then you can use the predefined noise
model in liquid over lay it on top of
your instance of quantum error
correction and then study and determine
the pseudo threshold using the universal
simulation you tomite and I actually did
this in our paper our 2014 paper on
studying the surface code under
realistic noise models we expressed the
surface code in liquid then we wrote a
set of different noise models simulate
the code under those different noise
models for a given decoder we ran many
instances of the code on our cluster
because we were performing Monte Carlo
sampling and obtained indicators of how
small service codes may perform in terms
of pseudo thresholds under realistic
noise we have since also studied magic
state distillation color codes the steam
code and stacked codes in liquid so
liquid allows one to be very flexible
also in the decoder so you can study
performance of a code under various
decoders we're actually in the process
of completing work now in this direction
with bettina haim and matt hastings
we're looking at different decoders for
say the surface code and color code
since liquid actually allows you to
write classical
programs say an f-sharp or C sharp it's
really easy to express your favorite
classical decoder and then pair it with
your quantum error correction simulation